so just so you know our team when you
walk by they're like there's captain
ryan like everyone's very excited to
have you here everyone oh so canadian i
was gonna say is there a different
flavor when it comes to jfl
i'm never here long enough to like
immerse myself but my daughter who's
british because i've lived in england
for 15 years she always says like
everyone at the coffee shop is so nice
and everyone on the street is so nice
and i'm like i don't know if that's jfl
or if that's canada i can't remember but
she definitely thinks everyone's like
the best oh i love the accent
you can't do it perfectly well but like
no it's good she's starting to sound
more american because of social media
and everyone goes she sounds like you
i'm like no she sounds like her phone
yeah she's not like her phone i love
that sad um so this is so exciting that
you're here i mean just for last month
you're all celebrating its 40th
anniversary how special is it to be here
with all the comedians everyone's back
seeing shows
i think jfl stands out as like
an international coup for people to be
invited people to be asked you know big
american comedians come here like kevin
hart's here and amy schumer's here and
i'm so excited to see them chelsea
handler was here last night
um and then to be british and be invited
it's like
hopefully you reach a level of success
where you're doing your own tours but
that means you don't get to see any of
your friends anymore it's a double-edged
sword so when we come into jfl we get to
see people that we admire but also
friends we made growing up like growing
up as little baby comedians and we get
to hang out so i mean it is always the
big festival that everyone wants to come
to that's awesome and not to make you
pick your favorites but is there one
community in particular that you are so
excited to see
well i don't really i have a baby i keep
having children and i'm pregnant again
oh my god congratulations morgan
i'm 39 years old we can't be messing
around with time
i understand that so i just keep getting
pregnant so i can't really go out and
have fun and see shows because i'm
beholden to all these dependents
but
i'm on a gala with jimmy carr who's my
very good friend in england i get to see
all the time rick mercer's on that
galaxy so my mom's excited about that
she's uh
excited to come see probably other
people not me fortune feinstein
i know i opened well opened i didn't
open for amy schumer i was one
beginner comedian on a bill with many
other beginner comedians when amy
schumer was at the wilson amphitheater
in toronto i didn't get to meet her then
and i don't think i'll get to meet her
this week
but she has always been one of my very
favorites i feel like amy schumer's
comedy is like a best friend telling me
a secret and that's the kind of comedy i
try to do i know it's true well i mean
people love you so much backstage
catherine did so well no it didn't no it
didn't really it didn't
we loved it that's nice of you to say
but it didn't get the numbers that they
hoped for so i don't know if we'll do
series two damn okay so i was gonna say
when it comes to series two
have you ever thought about doing
canadian version
showcase the canadian comedians that's a
that's a no no one showcases canadian
comedians why i don't know
they have to leave and become important
overseas how many canadian comedians are
on it just for laughs
not enough howie mandel me am i on just
for last because i'm famous here no i
left
and i feel like that needs to change and
i don't blame the comedy industry or
anything else i think geographically
it's quite hard for canadian comedians
because your gig like your gigs in
winnipeg but you're based in vancouver
like
it's a big old place where a lot of
people invest on going out to see ice
hockey so i would like to see more
canadian audiences outside of marial and
outside of these places that are so rich
with stand-up
going out to see like live music live
theater live spoken word live comedy and
all the little cities and towns that
would be great and then we'll see more
canadian comedians doing amazing because
they're so funny that's amazing
um but i agree with you you are right
when you start like going down the list
of all the action that's like it is
morgan yeah no it's good it's not a
popular opinion but it's a secret
opinion that is true uh so i'm
definitely talking to canadians who've
been named you know the new faces of
comedy school this year do you have any
advice for up-and-coming comedians
leave i know
and you're gonna give me an honest
opinion
no i feel like comedy now has changed i
think just in the last few years i'm
noticing in england anyway that a lot of
these up-and-comers are real
business-minded people they're
self-starters they're on socials they're
making their own videos they're finding
a side door into comedy during a
pandemic and i feel like comedy always
finds a way but it doesn't seem to be
the same as it used to be like when i
was starting in toronto at yuck yucks
you would put you would ring up like a
landline
and put your name on a voicemail to go
on the amateur night and then you'd ring
up again on a wednesday and listen to
hear if your name is on the amateur
night and you do five minutes and you
did that kind of forever until you were
offered a support slot then you get paid
like i don't remember what was 30 maybe
to do 15 minutes and and you'd have to
work your way up like that i don't know
that that system exists in the same way
i think a lot of people are using social
media
making videos
it's exciting for me to see but it's a
whole different world so my only advice
that i think um is evergreen
is to cultivate your authentic voice
never to do an impression of anyone else
and then you'll find your audience that
way that's good advice
so you're gonna be a mom of three yeah
how are you feeling i feel better now
that's why i'm like baggy because i
don't like drinking
it i want the single men of my eyes to
think they still you know might have a
shot
i don't like to walk around looking like
damaged goods
so um i feel better now in the beginning
pregnancy is awful i mean it's really
horrific in the beginning and especially
with a new baby my son just turned one
oh my god i know
but now i feel amazing i'm really
excited but i can't have caesar's and
that's well it could have a virgin
caesar i guess this is not the same i
can have poutine still then we're fine
you're you're you're going to find
enough of that here yeah i'm excited
about canadian food and dill pickle
chips yes love i love dill pickle chips
i like ketchup chips too yes i love
ketchup i love all dressed i mean we
could go on all day with a special crisp
review in england i will say we have a
real thriving comedy scene but we don't
have any good food
at all english food is absolute trash
good to know
don't go there for the culinary and we
have nice restaurants but no i don't
like nice restaurants i want caesar
putin do pickle chips so i like you
thank you and i love your stuff thanks
you